[Music]
if we have a function vy equal to f of x
we now know how to find its derivative
at a particular value of x so related to
each value of x we get a number which is
equal to the slope of the tangent line
there therefore can you tell me if the
derivative of a function is also a
function yes the derivative of a
function gives us a new function in this
video we will understand what this means
as well as its implications for example
consider the function y is equal to x
squared previously we'd found that at a
particular value of x let's say x1 the
derivative of this function is equal to
2 times x1 but now notice that x1 is an
arbitrary value of the variable X that
is it can be any value of x so let's
replace it by X here and also let's say
the derivative is denoted by a variable
Y Prime
therefore this means that for each value
of x there is a value of y Prime related
to it which is the derivative of f of X
at that point it means this relation is
a function so we see that finding the
derivative of a function gives us a new
function this function is called the
derived function here the independent
variable is X while the dependent
variable is y Prime at a particular
value of x the value of the derived
function f prime of X tells us the
derivative of f of X at that point now
let me ask your question what will be
the domain of the derived function do
you remember what we mean by domain of a
function
it's the set of all the values of the
independent variable X for which the
function is defined so for which values
of X will the derived function not be
defined let's say at a particular value
of x say x2 this function is not defined
then obviously we cannot find the
derivative of this function at x2
so it means that this derived function
will not be defined at X 2 so if set a
represents the domain of this function
then the derived function can only be
defined for the values of x in set a but
now in one of our previous videos we saw
that the derivative does not exist even
at some values of X in the domain of the
function it's because this limit does
not exist so this means that at the
values of x in set a where the
derivatives does not exist the derived
function will not be defined therefore
the domain of the derived function is
equal to all the values of X in the
domain of this function at which the
derivative exists let's take an example
to understand this consider this
function we saw previously we've seen
that for this function even though the
function is defined at X equal to zero
the derivative at X equal to zero does
not exist finding the derivative at
other values of X is simple for X
greater than zero we will get the
derivative to be constant at a value of
1 and for X less than 0 we will get the
negative 1 its graph will look like this
so we see that for this derived function
X equal to 0 will not be in its domain
but now notice that F prime is a
function so sadly differentiate this
derived function 2 what does this mean
let's find this out in the next part
you
this tells us that the variable y prime
is a function of the variable X so it
means that as the value of x changes the
value of y prime changes so we can find
the instantaneous rate of change of Y
Prime with respect to X that is the
derivative of F prime of X similar to
this it will be equal to the limit of
the average rate of change of F prime of
X now since this is a derivative of a
derived function of f of X it's called
the second derivative of f of X so it's
denoted by putting double Prime on F
like this now as seen earlier the
differentiation of F prime of X gives us
a new function called the second derived
function so we can further differentiate
it this gives us the third derivative of
f of X similarly we can find the fourth
derivative and so on these are all
called the higher-order derivatives of f
of X but what do these higher-order
derivatives tell us do they have any
significance well as we look at advanced
topics of calculus we will understand
why the higher-order derivatives are
significant for now let's look at an
example and understand the importance of
the second derivative consider this
object in motion we note that the speed
of the object tells us how fast or slow
it changes its position that is the rate
of change in position with respect to
time but it's the speed of any object in
motion always constant no right for
example as the object starts from rest
its speed starts increasing from zero we
say that it accelerates and when the
object has to come to rest its speed
decreases and we say that it decelerates
so acceleration of an object is the rate
of change in speed with respect to time
we know that speed is the rate of change
in position with respect to time so we
see that acceleration tells us the
second-order change in the position of
the object let's see what we mean by it
let's say the object's position is given
by this function of time we have seen
previously that the instantaneous speed
of the object at a time T 1 will be
equal to the derivative of this function
at T 1 so the derivative of this
position function will give us a new
function this function will tell us the
speed of the object at a time T now can
you tell me how we can find the
instantaneous acceleration at time T 1
it will be given by derivative of the
speed function at T 1 right this means
the acceleration function will be given
by the second derivative of the position
function so we know that the second
derivative of a position function tells
us about one important physical quantity
but wait there is something more
fascinating it turns out that for any
object in motion the force acting on it
is equal to its mass times acceleration
we know that the mass of an object is
constant so we see that the second
derivative of the position function
tells us the force acting on the object
therefore while studying the motion of
an object finding the second derivative
of the position function plays a central
role so until now we've seen many
aspects of the derivative of a function
also we've seen related to this idea
that there are many notations involved
one particularly important one we
haven't talked about is this one dy by
DX or DF by DX this notation suggests
that the derivative of a function is a
ratio of two quantities but we know this
is not the case as we've seen before the
derivative is the result of the limit of
this ratio it's not a ratio in itself
but we will see how useful this notation
is as we delve deeper into calculus in
essence it captures the whole idea of
the derivative let's see how consider
this function this symbol Delta is
always used to denote the change in a
quantity so if the value of x changes
from x1 to x2 then Delta X meets x2
minus x1
in other words X 2 will be equal to x1
plus Delta X now let's say at x1 the
value of the function is y 1 and at X 2
the value of the function is y 2 so
Delta Y means y2 minus y1 therefore the
numerator here can be denoted as Delta Y
now Delta X tends to 0 means the change
in X will get very very small close to 0
we say that the change is infinitesimal
we denote this infinitesimal change in X
by DX now we see that as Delta X tends
to 0 Delta Y will also get smaller and
smaller so we say that the change in Y
is also infinitesimal and we denote it
by dy
now since the derivative is the limit of
the ratio change in Y over change in X
we can intuitively think of it as the
ratio of infinitesimal change in Y over
infinitesimal change in X it means the
derivative tells us how the value of y
changes for an infinitesimal change in X
hence we can see that this notation
helps us intuitively understand the
derivative of a function but always be
aware that the derivative of a function
is not a ratio of two quantities it's a
number which is a limit of the ratio of
the two quantities would you rather have
any other notations for the derivative
of a function share your thoughts in the
comment section below and subscribe to
our channel to keep learning calculus
[Music]